Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Stefania Povolo
[Claudio] Buongiorno, ﻿Robert!
[Robert] Buongiorno.
[C] Robert è stato per anni un alpinista
dell’estremo di grande successo, no?
Nella sua vita si è sempre spinto
con passione e coraggio
in tutto quello che ha fatto.
Si è lasciato guidare
da questi due valori
Questi valori sono quelli
che fanno parte del nostro
emisfero destro del cervello, no?
La cosiddetta intelligenza emotiva.
Per questo motivo oggi abbiamo
deciso di condividere questo dialogo,
questa chiacchierata con Robert
e di farla fare a Luciano Ziarelli
che oltre ad essere il vocal coach
di TEDxTrento è stato anche il mio mentore
che, per un paio di mesi, mi ha seguito,
fatto molti caffè a casa sua, ecc...
lo invitiamo sul palco: Luciano Ziarelli.
(Applausi)
Nella sua seconda vita professionale
si è dedicato a questo lavoro, no Luciano?
Però questa è un'altra storia;
buon viaggio.
[Luciano] Grazie.
Robert, qui tutti hanno sentito
almeno un abstract della tua vita
che dire avventurosa è dire niente.
Certo più unica che rara.
La prima domanda
che mi viene in mente è:
“Cosa ti ha spinto a fare della tua vita
la vita che è diventata,
che oggi ci racconterai almeno un po'?”
Qual è la molla?
[R] Mah, è semplice: voglia di vivere
ed essere curioso.
La vita sedentaria non è per me.
Io credo che uno deve andare fuori
per poter ritornare.
Tanti non vanno mai via
e non possono mai ritornare.
Se noi abbiamo due sassi
e li mettiamo bene d'accordo
dobbiamo prima aprirli, guardare bene
e poi metterli daccordo.
Altrimenti la vita è grigia per me.
[L] Be’ questo deve essere vero.
A proposito della tua vita,
prima di diventare Robert
un esploratore estremo,
un alpinista estremo,
conosciuto in tutto il mondo,
ha fatto anche delle cose particolari.
Ha attraversato a piedi i deserti,
in Afghanistan, il Sahara…
E allora mi domando adesso,
poi sei arrivato la Groenlandia.
Ma c'è un fattore comune
che unisca questi due mondi
dell’infinito in fin dei conti?
Un deserto, l'altopiano della Groenlandia
che tu hai attraversato.
Qual è il fattore comune
se c'è un fattore comune per te?
[R] Difficile spiegarlo,
bisognerebbe andare lì.
[L] Fa un po freddo per noi, però.
[R] No, è semplice.
Comunque se noi andiamo su un 8.000
noi stiamo su dieci minuti sulla vetta,
abbiamo un raggio di 360°,
una vista incredibile, fantastica,
sull'altipiano groenlandese
che è due milioni di km quadrati.
Abbiamo 24 ore su 24 questa vista.
L'aria limpidissima,
cioè vediamo oltre 200 chilometri,
e questo vuole dire qualche cosa.
Uno che è stato lassù una volta
ha una malattia, diventa matto.
No, io non sono matto,
divento un po' matto,
però la libertà lassù è assoluta
non ci tiene niente è come su una nuvola
e siccome l’occhio non ha più quelle forme
come qui le montagne, per esempio,
dove sono nato e che amo,
non ha più quel punto fisso,
l’occhio non si tiene
e così abbiamo una distesa enorme
e questo vuol dire, subito,
che nel nostro cervello
e sotto la nostra pelle,
succede qualche cosa di libertà.
Qualche cosa di diverso.
Non c'è più limite:
è qualche cosa senza limite.
[L] Eh, certo senza limite,
dove però anche il senso del tempo
è diverso, ma non solo il senso del tempo.
Tu hai parlato di “si vede per 24 ore”:
ventiquattr’ore poi magari benissimo no,
perché insomma 22 ore di luce
o di buio, a seconda, c’è.
Come ci si può abituare a una vita
del genere proveniendo da dove vieni tu,
dall’Alto Adige?
Come si può vivere allo scuro
per tante ore o con troppa luce
e senza un limite di tempo o un
confine visibile? Come si fa?
[R] Mah, non è per tutti, credo.
[L] Come si fa per 30 anni, voglio dire,
perché per una settimana ci riusciremo
anche noi.
[R] Sì, ci vuole un po' di tempo
ma siamo lì proprio in quel punto;
non bisogna pensare troppo.
Bisogna farlo,
bisogna proprio farlo.
Bisogna andare dentro, non tirare giù
le tendine, di giorno,
cioè per 24 ore c'è solo sole.
Non bisogna tirare giù le tendine:
no, bisogna lasciarle aperte.
Il bioritmo nostro si ricarica di nuovo,
diventa normale, noi che eravamo così.
Adesso di notte facciamo le luci
così forte e abbiamo il giorno;
Di giorno chiudiamo tutto,
andiamo dentro da qualche parte,
è tutto chiuso: è notte o è giorno,
siamo completamente fuori della normalità.
E lì, invece, è la normalità.
Ci rendiamo conto dopo una settimana
o due che qualcheduno non ce la fa
perché pensa troppo:
“Adesso devo vedere,
sono 8:00 del mattino: mi devo alzare,
è mezzogiorno: devo mangiare...”
[L] A proposito di mangiare,
dalla cucina mediterranea o altoatesina
al cibo degli Inuit: che mangiano?
Che mangiate? Ci si abitua?
[R] Siamo in un punto un po’ debole
di questa situazione, (Risate)
perché bisogna sapere una cosa,
che ormai la caccia della foca
è stata abolita in Groenlandia
e in tutto il mondo:
abbiamo dei problemi enormi,
abbiamo vissuto per migliaia di anni
solo della foca: la foca per noi
erano le patate, la carne, l'insalata:
era tutto e, adesso, non c'è più.
Si mangiava solo la foca
ed era anche bello
perché nel nostro ristorante,
“La casa rossa”, abbiamo detto:
“Alle 7 di sera si mangia.”
Poi tutti i nostri ragazzi alle 7
non erano pronti, naturalmente,
il cuoco non era pronto,
poi io vado dentro e dico:
“Guardate ragazzi, sono le 7!
Dovete andare fuori a portare
il nostro menu”
e loro mi guardano e dicono:
“È veramente strano: ogni giorno
alle 7 in punto hanno fame.”
È una cosa strana, cioè vuol dire
che noi siamo un po' inscatolati,
cioè non abbiamo più quella libertà.
Quando si ha fame, si mangia.
Quello sarebbe giusto.
[L] Quello sarebbe giusto,
ma mangiare sempre foca?
[R] No, noi facciamo i menù…
[L] Ecco, raccontaci un po'
della “casa rossa”!
Dovete sapere che Robert ha avviato,
in questi ultimi anni,
una piccola attività imprenditoriale:
ha costruito un piccolo albergo.
Dà ospitalità a quanti dall'Europa
e dal mondo vogliono provare
l'ebbrezza della Groenlandia in una visita
più o meno breve, una settimana, 10 giorni
o quello che deve essere.
Com’è nata questa iniziativa?
Come funziona?
Chi ospitate in questa casa rossa?
[R] Giusto, io ho detto sempre ai ragazzi:
“Voi dovete mettere su una casa
così gli amici vengono dall'Italia,
dalla Germania, da tutto il mondo
e avete delle amicizie portano
un po' di soldi,
avete del lavoro e così via.”
Hanno detto sempre: “Non ce la facciamo,
non abbiamo niente. Fai tu!”
Gli ho detto:
“No, io non voglio fare.”
Le mura non mi piacciono,
io sono uccello: devo volare,
devo andare fuori e devo essere attivo.
Però poi ho fatto così e adesso abbiamo
un piccolo alberghetto
e stiamo insieme ed è il punto d'incontro
tra questa società e l’altra società
che è, assolutamente, in tante cose
il contrario. E il bello è,
che tutti hanno ragione.
Se noi ci mettiamo su una tavola rotonda
e parliamo di qualche cosa, del lavoro,
degli impegni, allora io dico la mia,
sono il capo, tutti acconsentono
e poi si alza l’altro e dice il contrario
e tutti dicono: “Ha ragione.”
Allora dico: “Ma come, quello lì
ha ragione o io?”
E poi si alza il terzo e quello dice
un'altra cosa, ma astronomica!
E poi dicono: “Vado via.”
Non c’è il consenso
ma tutti hanno ragione,
ma questa è la società.
Noi abbiamo la stima: ognuno fa la sua,
ognuno ha ragione per se.
[L] Robert, devo comunicarti purtroppo
che anche in italia le cose stanno così:
sembra che abbiano tutti ragione.
Tu ora è un pò che sei fuori,
le cose da un po’ stanno così...
Dai ci torniamo agli Inuit,
perchè è troppo interessante il racconto
che ci può fare Robert.
Dovete sapere che quest'uomo qui,
è l’unico al mondo che ha fatto un’impresa
che nessuno ha mai fatto prima
e che nessuno probabilmente farà ancora:
ha attraversato l'intero altopiano
della Groenlandia
assieme ad altri due pazzi
scatenati come lui.
Ci vuoi dire qualcosa di questa impresa,
come è nata? Cosa ti ha spinto a tentare
una cosa in cui francamente la probabilità
di sopravvivere, voglio dire,
era almeno pari a quella di...?
[R] Non era sempre facile, no.
Ho attraversato un paio di volte
la Groenlandia nella via classica,
che è 1.550 chilometri circa, e poi
ho pensato una cosa che si dovrebbe fare,
qualche cosa di speciale:
andare oltre quel limite.
Allora ho pensato di attraversare
la Groenlandia del Nord
per 1.400 chilometri e tutti hanno detto
che non è possibile,
assolutamente non possibile.
Tu non puoi tirare tanto peso
io, come te, non sono molto [muscoloso].
Ho trovato due amici
e allora siamo partiti senza radio,
senza collegamento telefonico,
non c'era il GPS,
abbiamo usato il vecchio sestante
come tanti anni fa con l'orizzonte tecnico
e abbiamo cercato di attraversare
questa distesa bianca.
Abbiamo avuto dei problemi, naturalmente,
ma è sempre così:
se uno vuole fare qualcosa di speciale è
per entrare nel futuro, per modo di dire.
E siamo proprio in quel punto lì,
possiamo sempre fare un piccolo passo
più in avanti, ma non è quello.
Un'invenzione è qualcosa di più:
è veramente diverso.
Se noi andiamo in una camera oscura,
per esempio, andiamo dentro,
guardiamo in giro e, con un piede,
teniamo la porta aperta.
E tutti credono che sono fuori:
“Mamma mia, quello lì va nel futuro.”
Cos'è il futuro? Nessuno lo sa.
È un’invenzione, è qualcosa qui dentro.
Se uno va veramente dentro,
chiude la porta e poi si inventa
quello che è possibile fare, lo fa.
E deve ritirarsi in se stesso.
Allora riesce a fare qualche cosa.
Il massimo. Quello lì sarebbe il futuro,
ma chi va dentro?
E questa spedizione era così.
[L] Ah, bene, senti,
a proposito di quella spedizione
molti esploratori dell’estremo
hanno raccontato che,
nei momenti più tosti dell'avventura,
alcuni di questi hanno avvertito
una presenza estranea, virtuale,
al loro fianco e, la maggior parte di loro
ne ha trovato, come dire, conforto.
Si sono sentiti incoraggiati
nei momenti della disperazione.
A te o a voi,
in questi 1.400 chilometri di nulla,
è accaduto qualcosa del genere oppure no?
[R] Giusto: avevo delle presenze,
era una cosa difficile per me.
Io andavo avanti per oltre 1.000 km
e i miei amici dietro sulla mia scia,
e ogni tanto avevo delle presenze.
Ho capito che qualcheduno sciava
vicino a me.
Ho sentito “ssh, ssh”: gli sci
che andavano avanti
e sapevo che ero solo,
ero assolutamente solo,
i miei amici molto indietro.
E poi ad un tratto ho avuto quelle paure,
una fobia incredibile,
una fobia non solo una paura,
e in quel momento mi sono accucciato
così dall’altra perché pensavo
che uno mi tirasse una mazza
proprio qui dentro.
Io credo che questo sia un fenomeno
[che accade] spesso in queste situazioni
così gravi, così difficili.
Io avevo paura di non poter uscire vivo,
non per la mia vita ma per i miei amici.
Era un senso di colpa per me.
Avevo anche altre presenze,
una cosa straordinaria, anche bellissima,
potrebbe essere anche positivo,
come hai detto tu oggi,
per me era negativo.
[L] Senti, io ho letto
i tuoi libri meravigliosi: nell'ultimo,
sul finale di questo tuo ultimo libro
scrivi che gli Inuit dicono:
“L'anima non muore, passa.”
Ecco, Robert, quando sarà fra cent'anni,
tu dove vorresti che passasse la tua
di anima, dove, o a chi e perché?
[R] Povero quello che prende la mia anima!
(Applausi)
Gli Inuit, Ivi, come li chiamiamo noi,
uomini di questa terra incredibile
vivono nell’oggi, non vivono nel domani.
Loro non conosco la parola “futuro”,
per esempio.
Loro pensano che l'uomo ha tante
piccole anime: le gambe sono anime,
le dita sono anime, la faccia è anima,
e poi hanno un’anima grande
che sarebbe il loro carattere.
Questa sarebbe la loro vita.
E dicono anche:
“Quello lì non ha un ombra!
Non vedi che quello lì
non ha un ombra?”
e dico: “Ma come non ha un’ombra?
Io vedo un’ombra.”
“No, non è un una vera ombra.”
E io dico: “Ma perchè?”
“Perché quello lì non ha un'anima.”
E questa anima, quando uno muore
-- e si muore molto facile --
allora passa nel prossimo nato
e quello lì acquista tutte le buone,
o cattive, facoltà di quell'anima.
Cioè quell’anima lì è passeggera.
[L] Caro Robert, io, ma penso tutti,
staremmo qui ad ascoltarti
per mezza giornata,
però il format di TED prevede
che 18 minuti siano il massimo.
Per cui è stato un onore averti con noi,
un piacere infinito, ti ringrazio.
[R] Grazie. (Applausi)